filming day always a fun day from the
film videos but what is more fun is
going to Universal now a lot of you guys
have probably seen people make videos
about going to Harry Potter world I have
never even seen Harry Potter like it's
that crazy how do not seeing Harry
Potter I don't know a classic in modern
and pop-culture modern and pop culture I
don't know hi I'm trying to come up
wearing this at home so well I'm not
sure every day were going I've been very
Potter won in Universal in Florida which
is actually really cool even not knowing
anything about Harry Potter it was still
awesome
so let's go I would like to go now stand
up let's roll look at that great haircut
everyone told Matt what a great haircut
he has what's your haircut oh mouth got
hair cut off to universal are you
driving nothing that's cool right we
finally made it
traffic was so bad it's probably
tomorrow or a few hours to get here I
got to pee so bad
this is a long long trip
[Music]
restroom break over now we're heading
into the part we're not even sure which
on the park closest is 16 mm late going
to get the late how do you pick it with
M support close we accrued number-one
Gym Leader that saddle - spot we got
three did that was a long time ago into
the park and we ended up getting the
front of the line pass so you can get
front of the line each ride one
let's ride rides and if you
[Music]
not a question question it may be given
to most people not having seen the movie
are we in a hook for that fog work so
where are we now are ogni clubs me oh
okay
learning hi Lily so you texted me you're
like hey do you want to go to Harry
Potter world I actually thought you were
joking
so you planned on coming here and you
don't live here so was even crazier but
we don't keep your Harry Potter games
all of the Harry Potters all their holes
yeah there's a Harry Potter movies yeah
I know baby really none of them others
like for I'm glad boy this is 9 my gosh
it was not very Potter at those and my
food am a very that was good I thought
that with the little sting but the
briefcase in every state with the rata
right otherwise in her ears were you
mean eyes the hot air Potter eyes is off
okay let's go wait are we in Hogwarts
now yeah
[Music]
really really fun I don't canal riding
mr. white or the immigrant
yes recalled I buy is exciting that ride
was legit 14 seconds disinfection no
startled regatta everywhere right there
walking around and we just met Manny and
he is telling us we gotta go to the
sorting hat
no wait supporting very noise the wonky
personally went yes alright joke your
show and please agree the want exposure
feel like a binge vent of watching old
Harry Potter movies and then I'm going
to get it I'm gonna understand
everything
let's go get sorted wait no this is the
sorting I want to launch uses want to
this alright this is real here offer oh
gosh so long
jeez no flash photography or tapping up
aluminum Chong thank you mean Caroline
oh oh we're ready Vinnie I will model
he's definitely
the butterbeer he's absolutely
[Music]
this water here I'm freaking out me so
happy for killing bill disability
government over here there's a lot of
candy in here
watch me hurt you if you have to keep up
and leave me long do Billy if I Harry
Potter world I'm really forward to
watching call Harry Potter movies in
disbelief
I feel like 10 years I love the dress
then slow
[Music]
[Applause]
you
by universal I was really fun sizable
fun I've had at Universal I think ever
actually there for many lines everyone
was super friendly met a lot of you guys
here it was really cool now we're going
to lift some dinner and then I have no
idea what else is going to happen this
vlog maybe it don't maybe more
[Music]